peter tiede von bild ich habe ja schon
einige pressekonferenz mit dem ethikrat
erlebt aber so eine noch nicht völlig
neue tonlage erste frage interpretiere
ich das richtig als eine art aufschreibt
und zweite frage was müsste denn ihrer
meinung sofort unmittelbar in der
langzeitpflege passieren damit die von
ihnen gerade deutlich benannten sachen
abgestellt werden oder gemindert werden
ja sie haben das genau richtig
interpretiert ich habe das ja auch am
anfang gesagt der ethikrat versteht dass
das etwas vorsichtiger ausgedrückt als
aufruf und ich hatte ja auch am schluss
gesagt es geht uns in der tat darum die
gesellschaft für anforderungen zu
sensibilisieren
die er vor allen dingen besonders
verletzliche menschen das sind ja
menschen in der pflege an uns
beziehungsweise an die gesellschaft
richten also von daher ist das in der
tat ein aufruf und wir sagen auch
ausdrücklich wir haben über jahre
vielleicht sogar über jahrzehnte der
pflege beauftragt
die bundesregierung hat dass er
ausdrücklich auch mal so formuliert die
pflege vernachlässigt und das hilft uns
jetzt besonders deutlich wo wir merken
mit welch hohen anforderungen pflege von
pflegebedürftigen von schwerkranken von
demenzkranken von sterbenden verbunden
ist und das sind nicht nur pflegerische
anforderungen im engeren sinne sondern
das ist ja auch der ganze kranz am
psychologischen und sozialen
fertigkeiten und was wir als bedeutsam
erachten besonders wichtig erachten sie
haben die frage gestellt ist eigentlich
die mischung von schutzmaßnahmen damit
mitarbeiter beziehungsweise bewohner
nicht infiziert werden
hier ist testung ein ganz bedeutendes
instrument wir haben schon vor vielen
monaten gesagt die tests strategien und
die test ressourcen müssen viel stärker
auch auf den bereich der pflege
konzentriert werden und der zweite
bereich ist die aktivierung von
bewohnerinnen und bewohnern und das
bedeutet dass wir natürlich auch die
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter in der
pflege unterstützen müssen sie brauchen
zusätzliches
das ist uns sehr wichtig die können
durch ehrenamtliche geleistet werden das
können frühere mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter seien oder jene die eben
ausreichend qualifiziert sind damit sie
in einer einrichtung arbeiten können und
die finanzierung muss über das
sozialgesetzbuch elf erfolgen weil
förderung von lebensqualität weil
aktivierung weil förderung von
fertigkeiten und kompetenz ein genuiner
bereich der pflegeversicherung darstellt
da wären dann auch die finanziellen
ressourcen und wir sind uns sicher wenn
man auf diese strategie schaut wie
können wir ehrenamtliche wie können wir
freiwillige gewinnen um eben in den
einrichtungen zu unterstützen dann
werden wir genügend finden was wir nicht
wollen
das ist uns ganz wichtig dass wir sagen
die mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter müssen
jetzt noch mehr tun nein es geht uns
darum die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter müssen umfassend unterstützt
werden damit sie eine fachlich und
ethisch anspruchsvolle pflege leisten
können und zwar eine pflege die genau
ihren vorstellungen entspricht
sie sitzt er öfter oben in der
bundespressekonferenz höre mir
pressekonferenzen an so moment hatte ich
da oben noch nicht ich hatte wirklich
gänsehaut und zwischenzeitlich kam einem
fast die tränen weil das war ein aufruf
an alle
es kann und darf so in der pflege nicht
weitergehen wir können nicht einfach die
alten sterben lassen ohne dass sie einen
sozialen kontakt haben wir können nicht
zulassen dass unsere alten in den
altenpflegeheimen isoliert sind
weil das man kontakte beschränken muss
das richtig das sagt auch der deutsche
ethikrat aber es kann nicht dazu führen
dass die alten vereinsamen und sich
deswegen die gesundheits zustand weiter
verschlechtert das war ein aufruf ein
aufschrei wie ich ihn hier noch nie
erlebt habe und schon gar nicht vom
deutschen ethikrat der steht er für
gedämpfte stimmung für vorsichtige
wortwahl
das war eine riesen klatsche eine volle
breitseite an die deutsche politik an
die pflegepolitik und der ganz klare
aufruf essen muss sich sofort etwas
ändern diese pandemie zeigt uns alle
notstände die wir in der pflege haben
das darf so nicht weitergehen muss sich
sofort ändern
es kann nicht sein dass in deutschland
menschen alleine sterben müssen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren